what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Carnage and in this video
Carnage is going to kill some Gods so in
the last video that we did which as
always you'll find a link to it down in
the description we basically had Carnage
who had returned without Cletus Cassidy
meaning it's the Symbiote just operating
on its own doing its own thing and what
karner's desires is power and so what he
had been doing was traveling around and
killing different villains for the sake
of attaining higher levels of power what
this did is it led to him alongside
basically a guy named Neely right Ken
Neely who's just kind of obsessed with
Carnage and that sort of thing traveling
out into other dimensions and we ended
up finding out that the place that they
arrived to is fartleheim the realm of
the Dark Elves now here's the thing
initially people scoff at them and I
never understood why the dark elves are
ridiculously overpowered right it's just
one of these crazy things so when they
show up here right what's actually
taking place is their arrival coincides
with the time of What's called the Great
hunt now the way this worked is for
those of you guys who are familiar with
like the Thor Mythos and all that stuff
stuff you had the war of Realms right
like literally all the nine Realms were
in the midst of this giant War where
they were facing off against malekith
the accursed and all of his Dark Elves
that's how powerful these guys were they
were literally conquering entire
realities like it's crazy how capable
they were but prior to all of this one
of the things that malekith did is he
basically went and faced off against a
kind of a wolf goddess and then stole
her cups and one of the things that did
was sort of elevate his power but Grant
him a kind of higher stature that's one
of the things to understand when it
comes to like Asgardian gods or any gods
associated with the Asgardian Mythos and
even when when you're talking about
characters like black panther it all
kind of Falls in line with being as much
ceremony as it is uh you know attaining
a higher level of power but malekith as
we know following the war of Realms Was
Defeated and he was basically taken to
the realm of Hell uh or at least
nippleheim if you want to call it that
basically taken to hell where he's ruled
over by hella and literally held
prisoner right like he's just gonna stay
there seemingly for all eternity now the
black bile was kind of like the inner
circle of malachy's forces the most
capable forces that he had kind of like
his uh I don't know like Special
Operations group right special ops guys
the issue is that after war of Realms
most all the the dark elves were either
defeated or destroyed so the black bile
is by and large just what's left of them
and so without a leader and largely
feeling kind of just a shade of their
former selves that what they do is they
kind of go back and reenact this hunt in
order to present themselves or at least
kind of build up their own confidence to
a degree and so what they say or at
least what their leader says is we need
six volunteers that can go out there and
literally steal the Cubs of a wolf
goddess just like malachythia Kirsten
and by doing that or successfully doing
that we can re-elevate ourselves at
least in our own eyes or even the eyes
of other people around here that we are
every bit as capable as we were under
malachith and potentially we may not
even need him now one of the things that
I want to specify here every single one
of these dark elves that you see is more
than a match for most every superhero on
earth right Captain America would just
get crushed by one of these dark elves
and it wouldn't even be funny Thor
himself right of course wielding mjolnir
and especially Thor as he exists now
with like the the Odin force or the Thor
force or whatever name you want to put
to it could obviously destroy these guys
right but what this is going to
illustrate here is just exactly how
powerful Carnage is and especially how
powerful symbiotes have become over the
years in Marvel Comics ever since the
original introduction of Venom back in
the 1980s and so one of the things that
goes on here is you do have a guy by the
name of zeist now zeist is by and large
considered the cast off of the black
bile he's there for no other reason than
the fact that their forces are so thin
they need every hand on deck if the
black bile was back to its you know it's
it's greatness right and had the large
number of soldiers that it had before
they wouldn't need this guy and in fact
they would reject his offer of
membership but truth about it they need
him because there's just so few of them
but what this guy's also been doing on
the side is improving himself now we'll
talk about that here in a little bit but
one of the things that he addresses
right off the bat is I know you guys
don't take me seriously I'm missing a
hand I've got a crooked spine nobody
here thinks that I'm worthy of being a
part of the black bile or even this
great hunt but regardless of the
circumstance let me join this right and
he says best case scenario I prove
myself to everybody here and you will
want me among your ranks because I am
one of the most formidable soldiers that
you have I will be the only one out of
the six who survives this hunt and
steals the Cubs of a wolf goddess right
he says worst case scenario I die and
you get to rid yourself of me so like
what's there to lose here right there's
this literally win-win and so ultimately
he's allowed to join the hunt now these
guys go out there with the expectation
of facing off against a goddess but
instead they meet Carnage now here's the
thing to know years and years ago right
when Venom was first introduced into
Marvel Comics he was just like like a
little more powerful than Spider-Man and
he could Dodge Spider-Man sense and like
that's it right like the spider sense
was useless against Venom and that was
like the big thing but over the years in
Marvel Comics by whatever Manner and
whatever means right stories and just
the evolution of the Symbiotes
themselves they've become a lot more
powerful if this was like the 1980s no
way would Carnage even in the early
1990s when Carnage first officially
showed up no way would he be able to go
toe-to-toe with any one of these dark
elves and stand a chance but notice this
this guy toys with him right keeping in
mind any one of these dark elves could
basically take on virtually any
superhero on Earth that that Carnage is
just toying with these guys dancing
around them having a good time killing
them on the spot now Neely is forced to
kind of watch all this but one of the
things that he finds so fascinating here
is that Carnage literally tells him your
task is to find zeist right this guy
here and kill him right that's your job
so literally he's gonna have to like
Neil is gonna have to hunt after a God
and kill himself now at this point we
jump back over to John shade right now
John shade of course was introduced in
the last video he's the cop who's hot on
the trail of Carnage but when Carnage
had initially met John shade and then
kind of imbued John shade with a portion
of his own Symbian right of Carnage of
the Carnage symbiote that what John Shea
did is he absorbed the memories and the
personality of Cletus Cassidy the
original Carnage host and so as a result
of that you have the situation where
John shade and Cletus Cassidy are
talking to each other in the sense that
Cletus is a voice inside of his head but
what's so wild about this is that as
they're kind of floating through this
ethereal Dimension and the little piece
of the Carnage symbiote inside of John
shade is the only thing keeping him from
just being crushed by the tidal forces
of space and gravity and all that kind
of stuff that it basically leads to him
being pulled out of this dimensional
plane and into the sphere of the pattern
maker now this is where things get
really interesting because now what's
happening is we're invoking the spider
verse so we don't really get a whole lot
of it here and in fact the pattern maker
is just kind of the newest iteration of
the person who controls the web of life
and Destiny right so a little bit of
explanation here you may find this
really really fascinating and in fact I
think you will so the way it works when
it comes to spider people is for years
and years and years in Marvel Comics you
just had Spider-Man right he's the guy
who just swung around with webs and
fought bad guys and crack jokes but over
the years what Marvel's done is they've
introduced this much larger Mythos so
you know how we have like the uh
spider-verse film that's coming out the
newest one right spider verse two
essentially the way all of that works
right using comic books is a kind of
bass line is you have the web of life
and Destiny and the web of life life and
Destiny is quite literally a gigantic
spider web that exists out there in some
other dimension but the the nature of
each individual thread of the web is
that that's what ties the different
spiders together and the pattern maker
herself right in this case Annie by
manipulating those threads is basically
kind of able to manipulate reality to a
degree right so quite literally she can
tug on one thread and instead of a Peter
Parker Spider-Man in another reality
becoming Spider-Man it's like Miles
Morales right like it's just kind of a
way to alter reality if they choose to
it's very ambiguous to a degree and it's
very finicky the way that Marvel uses it
reality warping is a lot easier to
understand when you just have a guy who
waves his hand and some crazy stuff
happens right so that's just kind of the
nature of comics but the overall gist of
this is that while the the destruction
of the web of life and Destiny doesn't
necessarily eradicate every spider in
existence right every Spider-Man Peter
Parker or spider-gwen or Miles Morales
what it does do is it takes away the
interconnectivity of all of them meaning
that they are just kind of marginally
weaker right they're not able to draw
off the power of each other across the
entirety of the Multiverse because in
the end of the day the web of life and
Destiny is what connects them all on a
kind of spiritual level and so Annie is
basically a like the daughter of Peter
Parker and Mary Jane Watson from an
alternate reality those are the guys who
remember Secret Wars in 2015 and you
remember the renew your vowel story arc
that that Annie that little girl this is
her right now if you don't know what
that means not a great big huge deal
right just a little bit of a fun moment
for people who are familiar with that
and who remember when we covered Secret
Wars eight years ago so here's the thing
God I can't believe I've been doing this
for over a decade it's crazy how long
all this has been going on so what Annie
really says here is that because she's
the new pattern maker and because she's
the one that's tasked with rebuilding
the web of life and Destiny she's having
a hard time doing it and the reason why
is because every time she tries to
reconstruct it she basically ends up
seeing the threads turning into Carnage
symbiotes right like just literally the
Symbiote itself now what this is is more
symbolic than anything else but
effectively it means that Carnage right
traveling throughout the mo the various
Dimensions like this throughout the
Universe and even the Multiverse that he
is kind of like a free radical he's not
where he's supposed to be and he's
basically disrupting a combination of
the flow of time and the natural order
of all things in existence but more so
than that the actions that he's
committed to right the things that he's
engaging in killing different gods
killing different villains and so on and
so forth that he's actually affecting
the nature of the universe itself and by
by gaining greater and greater levels of
power eventually he'll reach a place
where he will be unstoppable and no one
across the universe will be able to
defeat this guy and so what we end up
doing here is we actually jump away from
John shade and we jump back to Neely
who's ultimately met by Zeiss who kind
of just Springs out of nowhere now this
is where you get this really really
interesting story between the two
because what Zeiss really says here is
that he and Neely one right once Neely
kind of Reveals His Adventure that he
was a guy who's obsessed with just like
with attracting Carnage because he loved
the kind of Destruction and Mayhem that
Carnage represented only to find out
that once he met Carnage Carnes was a
lot more dangerous and more sadistic
than nearly originally thought their
Carnage has kind of been making fun of
him and just sort of tormenting him the
whole time that Zeiss finds a kind of
Common Ground there because while
zeiss's tormentors somewhat came in the
form of other Dark Elves that just
didn't really take him seriously and
considered him a cast off his greatest
Tormentor was himself because he saw
himself as less than both due to his
physical handicaps as well as his lack
of battle experience and so what he
tells nearly is he says unlike you who
basically just sits around moping and
just kind of wishing your life could be
better I actually did something about it
and what I did is I just started working
on myself and I started improving myself
I started exercising all the time like
literally building up my weaknesses into
physical strengths right I became
battle-hearted and while I can't wield a
Broad Sword because I like a second hand
to do so I became prodigious with a
dagger and the truth about this is that
if you walk up on an enemy with no
broadsword in sight they're not going to
take you seriously but if you're
deadlier with a dagger than anybody
could ever be with a broadsword you'll
Crush that enemy in the blink of an eye
because they'll never see it coming and
and that's what's so cool about this
because as this story is being told to
Neely literally Carnage is facing off
against these dark elves and just
ripping them to pieces I mean just
tearing their physical bodies apart I
mean these guys are getting absolutely
crushed and so what ends up happening is
Carnage faces off against the last guy
right he ends up meeting this last guy
outside of zeist who again is hanging
out with Neely as Carnage Encounters
this last dark elf that what kindness
does realizing the strength and the
prowess of this dark elf is he uses his
own symbiotes to conjure manifestations
of the other Dark Elves that he's killed
which is amazing because one it presents
a kind of psychological effect in the
sense that this guy's basically being
met with people that he knows and is
being forced to kill them but the second
thing is it leaves him outnumbered
because now it's fighting a variety of
Symbiotes all at the same time and so
the result of this is that this guy
falls pretty quickly and so following
that like the entire Landscapes open and
Carnage basically travels to face off
against these hellhounds and basically
capture them and so again as this whole
story is being told by zeist to Neely
and he's kind of spilling the beans
about everything that Neely is faced
with a choice because what Zeiss tells
him is he's like you've got two options
here the first is that we can work
together and we can just wait Carnage
out right we can literally have him face
I would let him face off against all
those guys and either he will kill them
in which case will understand how he
fights in a way to defeat him or they
will wear him down and then in turn even
if they don't kill him he'll still be so
weak we can kill him anyway but what you
have to do nearly is you have to make a
choice are you going to be Carnage's
lucky forever are you going to be this
guy that takes barking orders from
Carnage or or do you aspire to be
something more make your choice and so
what ends up happening is that we just
literally jump back to Carnage before we
find out what choice Neely made and as
he's talking to Carnage literally one of
the things nearly says is I don't
understand why we're doing all this like
the previous crimes that you engaged in
before when you seemingly first popped
up on the scene and you would like kill
people and you would write Carnage Rules
on the walls in your own blood or in
their blood there was a beauty to it
right there was a a kind of uh art art
form to what it was that you were doing
now it kind of feels indiscriminate
what's the benefit of killing these dark
elf Gods what's the benefit of of
killing these cops and literally what
Carnage says is you think that way
because you think small because you live
in a small world and you perceive your
world in a small way and he says I'm
thinking much bigger than this I'm
thinking much much larger than this
right stop thinking so small and he's
like what makes you think that I killed
all these hellhounds these are all a
means to an end I killed all but one and
then I harnessed its power right what
this does is now it puts me in a
position to where I've absorbed the
power of all these dark elf Gods right
so now I'm imbued with godly power and
now I've ensnared a a hellhound which
will allow me access to get to wherever
I want to specifically to the realm of
hell and so he says what have you done
with regards to the task that I beset
you did you take out zeist and the
response of Neely is yes that he trusted
me all the way until the very last
moment right he confided in me he saw me
as a kind of kindred spirit and in that
moment I used his weakness to create his
demise and I slit his throat using the
very tiger that he gave me considering
me to be a weaker version of him and
that and then once they actually get to
the body he's strung it up right this
guy is seemingly dead right like
literally he just strung his body up and
when he asked Carnage why did you have
me go after this guy in the first place
the response of Carnage is amazing here
he says because he was you because he
was you right he was you before right
the person who was weak the person who
was pathetic by killing him you've
killed that weak empathetic version of
yourself you become stronger with every
death that you engage in and so the
result of this is that when Neely asks
okay fine like where do we go next the
response of Carnage is the one place
that we need a hellhound to get to and
that's when we pick up with John shade
and we end up finding out that John
shade after being tasked by Annie was
effectively taking out Carnage due to
the influence Carnage is having on the
very nature of the universe itself that
John's shade is actually teleported to
the place that Carnage is going to in
order to cut him off at the pass and the
place where Carnage is going is nipple
also known as hell also known as the
realm of hella the Asgardian goddess of
death herself and if you guys thought
that anything you've seen so far is
interesting it gets nuts after this but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace